ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
à suivre cet après-midi sur notre
antenne à partir de 17h30 l'audition de
jean-louis borloo le ministre de
l'écologie et entendu par les sénateurs
de la mission d'information commune sur
les conséquences de la tempête xynthia
mais avant cela les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du projet de loi
relatif au grand paris ce matin valérie
pécresse la présidente du groupe ump au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france a
déclaré qu'elle ne souhaitait pas que le
grand paris devienne un bouc émissaire
après les élections régionales
je ne veux pas que ce projet loi fasse
l'objet d'une polémique politicienne a
déclaré la ministre alors que gauche et
droite s'affrontent depuis hier sur ce
thème au sénat tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle bonne séance à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de
la discussion du projet de loi relatif
au grand paris
dans la discussion des articles nous
passons à l'examen de l'amendement
numéro 9 de l'article 1er deux
amendements identiques font l'objet
d'une discussion commune l'amendement
numéro 9
il est présenté d'un madame à ça si oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur ni
chers collègues
donc cet article a été réécrit nous
l'avons longuement évoqué hier soir mais
je dois vous dire que de toute façon
avant même avant même sa réécriture nous
nous apprêtions à déposer un sur un
amendement de suppression
tout simplement parce que la nouvelle
formulation qui nous est présentée n'est
toujours pas à nos yeux satisfaisante
alors je vais dire pourquoi d'abord
parce que cet article s'apparente plus à
un exposé des motifs synthétique qu'à un
véritable article de loi
selon nous il ne comporte aucune
disposition de portée normative et il
propose donc un texte d'affichage
qui n'a vraiment rien à voir avec le
contenu réel de ce projet de loi
donc il ya quelques affirmations qui
sont contenus dans cet article comme
celle relative à la construction de
70000 logements par an et ces
affirmations ne sont que des promesses
qui ne sont en aucune façon des
engagements législatives comme on dit de
façon populaire les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent ce projet donc
qui vise à la création de la société du
grand paris et l'établissement public de
paris saclay est en fait un vrai projet
de société qu'on essaie ici de nous
vendre pour mieux le mettre en oeuvre
ensuite sur d'autres territoires de
notre pays
dans le même temps ce texte est portée
par un projet urbain que nous ne pouvons
cautionner à la lecture de la première
phrase de l'article 1er on voit bien en
tout cas il symbolise tout ce qui nous
qui peut nous séparer
notre vision c'est celle d'une métropole
solidaire qui propose un développement
harmonieux partagée par toutes les
populations qui vivent et y travaillent
et quant à voula votre ambition c'est
d'ailleurs vous le dites d'unir la ville
de paris aux grands territoires
stratégiques de la région ile de france
mais je trouve quand même que même
disant cela
le reste du texte est quand même en
contradiction avec cette phrase
par ailleurs les soi-disant atouts de ce
projet urbain sont en fait présenter de
façon très éloignée de la réalité et
notamment des préconisations contenues
dans son texte
je voudrais dire que une ligne de métro
automatique et est appelée réseau de
transport interconnectés alors que rien
n'est prévu dans ce domaine donc ce
projet contribuerait à la maîtrise de
l'étalement urbain
alors qu'au contraire ils l'organisent
c'était tellement urbain en faisant
passer la ligne de métro rapide en
certains endroits par des territoires
éloignés encore faiblement urbanisé
enfin et j'en terminerai là il est écrit
que ce projet vise à réduire les
déséquilibres alors qu'il les organisent
les structures et les renforce donc
contre ce projet de loi parce que nous
sommes contre ce projet de loi nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
merci cher qu'un amendement 237 il est
présenté par madame voynet
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
serait-elle et à mesdames et messieurs
dans cet article 1er on nous raconte une
belle histoire
on nous décrit une ambition forte
louable parfois mais persiste très
fortement l'impression que les outils
mis en oeuvre sont en total décalage
avec les moyens qui permettraient
d'aller au delà des déclarations de
principe de ces articles 1
nous avons le sentiment d'une part que
les le projet global qui nous avait été
promis n'est pas au rendez vous un
projet qui permettrait de remédier à
l'étalement urbain aux effets de coupure
générés par la pratique et les 60 on
installait façon très brutale à travers
des territoires dont la réalité n'est
pas prise en compte des infrastructures
lourdes lignes ferroviaires ou autoroute
on a le sentiment que les outils que
vous nous proposez ne permettront pas de
remédier
au mitage du territoire par des hangars
métalliques par des immeubles de bureaux
par des zones commerciales au parking
immense et souvent désolé
voilà l'ordinaire de tant de nos villes
voilà l'épreuve concrets auxquels nous
devons remédier et pour lesquels le
grand métro souterrain construit un
grand renfort de dispositifs exorbitant
du droit commun n'apportera pas de
réponse quant aux contrats de
développement territorial vous
conviendrez que cet article on parle
d'une façon curieuse assez éloigné des
canons de la langue française
ce réseau s'articule autour de contrats
de développement territorial diable
est-ce que c'est au tour de
l'infrastructure qu'on repense des
stratégies de développement
ou est-ce que l'infrastructure se greffe
sur les contrats de développement
moi j'avoue j'ai pas compris mais en
regardant l'article qui définissait les
contrats de développement territorial
j'ai compris qu'il était facultatif
qu'il serait conclu directement entre
l'état et les communes qu'il ferait
l'impasse sur la région et qu'il se
substituerait probablement à certaines
périodes d orientation des contrats de
projets sans forcément échapper au
risque de se pendre âge qui a été
pointée tout à l'heure pour faire court
cet article ne correspond pas à la
réalité du projet de loi il est indiqué
que les collectivités territoriales les
citoyens sont associés à l'élaboration
et la réalisation du projet en fait les
citoyens n'ont pas eu leur mot à dire
la grande concertation 30 ans clamé par
le gouvernement était plus un moyen de
légitimer un projet déjà ficelé un
projet de nous savons tous qu'il a été
travaillé sur la base une logique
d'experts dans des bureaux et façon
relativement discrète
avant même que le moindre débat local
soit engagée dans ce premier alinéa
il est également indiqué que le projet
de loi vise à réduire les déséquilibres
sociaux territoriaux et fiscaux au
bénéfice de l'ensemble du territoire
national nous sommes là face à face à un
exemple frappant de langue de bois
comment pouvez-vous faire croire à qui
que ce soit que la mise en service d'un
métro automatique reliant entre elles
des zones d'emploi ou de développement
économique ainsi que la construction
d'un cluster en dehors de paris pourrait
réduire les inégalités sociales de la
région est encore mieux toute la france
ce n'est pas parce que les hommes
d'affaires feront le trajet orly la
défense plus rapidement que les
inégalités se réduiront dans l'oise où
la marne
malgré des intentions louables de la
commission ad' hoc du sénat comme
d'ajouter un objectif chiffré pour la
construction des logements en ile de
france
il n'ya pas non plus de garanties sur la
réalisation de ceux ci l'objectif
d'ailleurs pas présent dans l'étude
d'impact de la loi c'est clair on est là
face à une sorte de cavaliers subterfuge
trouvé par la commission pour permettre
d'interpeller le gouvernement sur la
nécessité enfin de mettre en place une
politique de construction de logements
pour rattraper le retard
terrifiant qui constitue l'arrêt et la
réalité de cette région
en clair nous demandons la suppression
de cet article qui a été élaborée comme
le reste du texte sans réelle
concertation les élus et les populations
locales et qui consacre la reprise en
main par l'état de l'aménagement notre
région merci jacques relègue monsieur
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci monsieur le président monsieur b
mes chers collègues il est de bon ton
d'attaquer l'article 1er en disant qu'il
recouvre beaucoup plus de matière que ce
que celles qui sont dans le texte
je rappelle avec l'article premier parle
du transport elle parle de la recherche
et de l'innovation
elle part des contrats de développement
territorial qui sont les trois éléments
essentiels du texte et vouloir comme
vous l'avez fait à la fois madame de ce
que tu es et madame voynet dire qu'il
n'ya qu'un problème de transport dans ce
texte est une caricature beaucoup trop
simple la commission spéciale a donc ré
écrit cet article
alors que l'assemblée nationale avait
introduit un certain nombre de logements
elle ajouté l'objectif de logements qui
sera développée par la suite
dans un chapitre spécial comprenant un
certain nombre d'hommes d'éléments qui
permettront de valoriser et d'essayer de
rendre beaucoup plus crédible la
poursuite et j'espère l'atteinte de
l'objectif de 70000 logements
par conséquent la commission tient à cet
article
et elle s'oppose aux deux amendements
merci le rapporteur monsieur le ministre
la vie du gouvernement même avis que
monsieur le rapporteur
je crois que j'ai eu l'occasion dans la
déclaration générale de de dire en quoi
je ne peux qu'être d'accord avec cet
article
la même voie n'est dire que je reprends
l'objet de votre amendement
l'aménagement du territoire proposé une
s'inscrit dans une vision libérale du
développement de la région ile-de-france
déjà faudrait-il définir ce qu'on entend
par vision libérale autour de pôles de
compétitivité encore fort et il est un
peu précis sur ce que sont les pôles de
compétitivité
ayant été à l'origine il ya quelques
années des pôles de compétitivité je
pourrais en parler amplement cela n'a
strictement rien à voir avec les pôles
de développement puisque dans un certain
nombre de ces pôles de développement il
y a plusieurs pôles de compétitivité et
ce en relation avec les besoins des
franciliens
permettez moi simplement de souligner à
nouveau que le réseau de transport est
un réseau qui met 5 millions de
franciliens en relation directe avec les
gars ils ont le tracé des gares pour
l'instant imaginer je pense que
c'est un propos qui est à tout le moins
très excessif de dire qu' il n'y a pas
de relation avec les besoins des
franciliens
merci monsieur le ministre pour
explication de vote madame briques
oui monsieur le président nous avons
expliqué tard
hier pourquoi le groupe socialiste ne
présentait pas d'amendement à cet
article 1 que le rapporteur a
effectivement par rapport à la version
de l'assemblée écrit à nouveau mais
parce que nous développons notre vision
et nous avons expliqué pourquoi notre
vision était fondamentalement différente
de celle qui est exprimée par le
gouvernement et par le rapporteur à
l'article 2 cela étant l'amendement de
suppression de nos collègues du groupe
communiste défendu par un damas ainsi et
l'amendement défendu par de suppression
défendu et argumentée par madame voynet
nous les votes euros et je voudrais
rapidement vous dire pourquoi parce que
dans l'art et le travail de réécriture
que vous avez effectué monsieur le
rapporteur
il ressemble finalement plus
outre le fait que ce sont des bonnes
intentions et une juxtaposition
finalement de bonnes intentions mais
vous n'en tirez pas les conséquences
dans la suite du texte jean jeu j'en
prends 2 par exemple
vous mettez le l'objectif que nous avait
recommandé monsieur apparu lors de son
audition devant la commission spéciale
de 70000 logements et vous écrivez qu'il
doive être géographiquement et
socialement adaptée en ile de france
sauf que à l'article 19 bis c'est le
préfet de région qui les territoriales
''sera alors bon ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'état décidera
effectivement où il est bon d'avoir du
logement sans qu'on puisse en discuter
et et que ici et a fortiori
dans dans les communes et il est fort à
craindre que compte tenu du ce qui s'est
passé et de ce qui se passe encore
eh bien les communes qui n'ont pas fait
l'effort nécessaire à l'accueil des
logements sociaux continuent à ne pas le
faire que puisque on a l'habitude de
concentrer les logements sociaux plutôt
à l'est qu'à l'ouest
donc on continue on peut continuer de la
même manière donc nous n'avons aucune
assurance concernant ce principe que
vous énoncez ensuite et puis on pourrait
épiloguer sur le problème structurel du
défaut de logements en ile de france
notamment avec le prix du foncier je le
développe pas la commission des finances
fait un gros travail a commencé un gros
travail sur la fiscalité immobilière
on pourrait aussi développer le fait que
le même gouvernement a dans la période
récente et déjà depuis quelques années
femi des dispositifs fiscaux dont même
votre majorité convient que elle ne
correspond pas aux objectifs de logement
et notamment de logements qui
correspondent à des besoins des
populations
et puis vous dites vous affirmez la
double boucle financé par l'état
alors ça c'est un principe que vous
ressassez à l'envi mais quand on regarde
ce que vous appelez financements d'état
je vais pas développer que ce soit la
dotation en capital près sur le
remboursement des prêts à l'automobile
dont nous reparlerons quand nous
attaquerons les articles financiers à
partir de l'article 9
que ce soit la valorisation foncière que
ce soit les baux etc
donc permettez que tout ça c'est de ces
du financement de l'état à bon compte
surtout quand vous alimentez la société
du grand paris par un impôt qui sera
finalement versé par le l'autorité
organisatrice de l'île de france
c'est facile de dire que c'est financé
par l'état
alors que on pourra le démontrer très
facilement ces financements ne sont pas
au rendez vous et ça vous permet à
l'article 3 si vous continuez de tenir
bon sur
de faire sauter la consultation publique
sur arc express ça vous permet de dire
chacun chez soi
l'état fait ce qu'ils estiment devoir à
faire la région elle fait ce qu'elle
estime devoir à faire et puis il n'ya
pas de coopération entre les deux donc
là vous êtes sur une mauvaise voie qui
n'est pas celle de la discussion qui
n'est pas celle de la concertation est
évidemment à fortiori encore moins à
celle de la de la négociation donc à
partir de là nous demanderons la
suppression de cet article et nous
défendrons notre vision précisément à
l'article 2
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur n'a hélas pour l'explication de
vote pour l'instant
complètement de ce que vient dire nicole
bricq
nous manifestons notre contentement par
rapport aux rapporteurs qui a essayé
d'améliorer le texte je le comprends
bien mais il est très difficile
d'améliorer un très mauvais texte et
malgré cela au lieu d'avoir une
philosophie d'ensemble de ce qui est
dans cette non seule loi on a une juste
apposition ii de mesures qui sont toutes
plus étonnantes les unes que les autres
alors évidemment si jamais cette cette
introduction était une conclusion est
que par là même vous acceptiez noah
moment on améliorerait ainsi largement
le texte si on pourrait discuter
effectivement de cette juste position
mais à la discussion hier qui a été mené
on a vu que vous étiez vent debout
contre nos amendements et que par là
même nous avons peu de chances de faire
passer un certain nombre de nos idées
alors pour citer quelques exemples
contenues dans cet article ont péri vous
parlez de développement économique
durable vient nous vous présenterons un
amendement à l'amendement 1 117 et on
verra bien si vous enterrer le grenelle
de l'environnement ou si vous le
ressusciter lorsqu il semble
qu'actuellement il y a
il y a quand même deux deux différences
de parole du président de la république
louhans effectivement l'écologie et
l'enterrant quand il s'agit de parler
aux agriculteurs pas par exemple
donc faudrait savoir ce gouvernement ce
qu'il souhaite souhaite faire vous nous
parlez de réduire d éclipse sociaux
territoriaux et fils cours bénéfice de
l'ensemble du territoire national
je vous ai dit et redit que l'ess est
particulièrement sacrifier et que ce
n'est pas en mettant un monstre période
plateau de saclay en développement le
nord de l'ile-de-france et à monstre
technologique excusez moi pour ceux qui
sont dans ce secteur-là et et puis et
puis en continuant disons le travail qui
est fait à la défense des dizaines de
milliers de mètres carrés de bureaux que
vous programmez par exemple à l'est et
vous me l'avez dit en réunion quand on
faisait partie de la cité descartes et
quand je vous ai terre interrogez votre
réponse a été phénoménal vous m'avez dit
il faut laisser du temps au temps pas
seulement à l'ess
excusez moi de vous dire on n'a pas le
temps on n'a pas le temps parce que oui
vous avez un maître en la matière
mais ceci dit vous vous ne je ne parle
pas de trois avions et aucunement et
mais disons en la matière laisse le
parisien est laissé pour compte et
laissé pour compte et par là même vous
avez bien dit que du côté de clichés aux
poussières et son allié du côté du
bourget mais faudrait aussi penser
qu'ils allaient c'est la certitude de ce
département et du val de marne ne se
situe plus au sud
effectivement de clichy montfermeil
donc il n'y aura pas pour nous disons
dès la réduction des déséquilibres
sociaux et même la réduction du nombre
d'emplois qu'il y a dans ce secteur
extrêmement modeste par rapport à la
population en âge de travail de
travailler et on a des résultats
extrait extraordinairement inquiétant
inquiétant non dans nos zones urbaines
sensibles
le chômage des jeunes par exemple s'est
développé de façon exponentielle
exponentielle quand c'est chez ces
jeunes sont au chômage et que aulas non
ce show mal déjà 25% au moins voire 30%
et qu'il procède de 37 à 40 %
supplémentaires de chômage on peut
s'inquiéter donc est ce que c'est le
métro qui va effectivement réduire ces
inégalités
donc je pourrais je pourrais continuer
bien évidemment sur ces logements aussi
où d'un côté on a les emplois à la loire
et de côté on a les cas sociaux excusez
moi dont on s'occupe puisque à
neuilly-sur-seine on s'occupe quand même
beaucoup moins des cas sociaux qu'à
delhi sur marne un mail à l'emploi est
là et il ne l'est pas il ne l'est pas
effectivement à l'est donc développons
effectivement ceci met pas en crédits
bras pas en attention comme le dit
l'article le premier mais plutôt plutôt
en disant on va réaliser ça on va faire
en sorte que les entreprises vont être
guidés pour s'installer ici et là et et
non pas l'inversé
en continuant je me rappelle quand même
cet amendement fait en catimini disons à
la veille des vacances pour augmenter le
nombre de mètres carrés de bureaux la
construction du nombre de mètres carrés
de bureaux à la défense c'est quand même
complètement anormal que ceux ci soient
ainsi que ce se soit passé ainsi donc
rééquilibrer reste et faisons en sorte
que cet article 1er je termine monsieur
le président soit en fait une réalité
dans ce projet de loi merci chers
collègues pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote alors que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter ce que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement numéro
9 a bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté neuf
amendements et sous-amendement font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
tout d'abord l'amendement de numéro 10
il est présenté par monsieur verra
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire d'état mes chers collègues
par cet amendement nous proposons de
réécrire donc au travers d'une cinquième
version cet article premier conformément
donc à notre vision d'un grand projet
d'aménagement de la région ile de france
ainsi nous souhaiterions placé au coeur
de ce projet la réduction des inégalités
territoriales et non le développement de
pôles déjà favorisés nous estimons en
effet qu'il est possible de faire de
notre région un territoire d'excellence
en matière de services publics de
développement du logement social et des
transports publics accessibles
permettant le désenclavement par un
maillage fin de l'ensemble du territoire
la lutte contre les inégalités socio
économique doit être l'angle d'attaqué
principal du grand projet d'aménagement
ce qui n'est évidemment pas le cas dans
ce texte
nous déplorons également l'absence de
tout volontarisme en termes de politique
industrielle et à cette fin nous
proposons de conditionner l'aide
publique aux entreprises à la
réalisation d'objectifs d'amélioration
qualitative de l'offre d'emploi nous
souhaitons rétablir partout
l'association des représentants élus des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'ensemble des institutions compétentes
et légitime régions départements
communes stif que ce projet de loi
écarte systématiquement en tout état de
cause le débat public ne peut répondre à
cette exigence car à la fin de la
consultation seul près vos droits
la volonté de la société du grand paris
dans laquelle l'état est majoritairement
représentés nous pensons qu'il est
indispensable que l'aménagement du
territoire soit pensé en fonction des
besoins et des attentes des franciliens
pour cette raison les enjeux liés au
développement de la région-capitale
exclut toute action autoritaire et doit
s'appuyer sur une étroite concertation
entre l'état et les collectivités ainsi
que l'association aude et 6
des franciliens eux mêmes nous estimons
également qu'un homme est d'ailleurs un
aménagement durable du territoire
francilien repose sur quatre piliers
d'actions prioritaires et conjoints le
logement les transports l'emploi et les
équipements publics ne pas penser de
manière coordonnée ses exigences vous à
l'échec toute action de ce projet du
grand paris laissant place aux logiques
ségrégative et spéculative une telle
action suppose des engagements
financiers lourds qui doivent être
formalisées dans de nouveaux contrats de
projet et non de manière
particulièrement vague comme le fait ce
texte
en effet les modes de financement
préconisé notamment par notre rapporteur
pour ce grand huit vont dans le sens
d'une valorisation des terrains
attenants aux gars
al'inverse des exigences de mixité
sociale que seule une maîtrise publique
du foncier et de l'aménagement permet
pour toutes ces raisons mes chers
collègues nous vous invitons à adopter
cet amendement de réécriture merci chers
collègues leurs amendements 238 il est
présenté par madame monet
merci monsieur président ou s'ils me
disent tu n'as faisait messieurs par cet
amendement après avoir en vain proposé
de supprimer la rédaction actuelle
l'article nous vous proposons de le
réécrire
nous souhaitons redéfinir les objectifs
de ce texte insisté sur la nécessaire
amélioration de la qualité de vie des
habitants la réduction des inégalités
sociales et territoriales
l'amélioration des équipements et des
services publics objectif que nous
jugeons déterminant pour l'attractivité
économique des territoires
il est en effet possible de faire
d'autres régions un territoire
d'excellence en matière de services
publics de développement du logement
social transports publics accessibles
permettant la desserte de quartier qui
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas les
inégalités socio économiques doivent
être l'angle d'attaqué principal d'un
projet d'aménagement comme celui ci ce
qui n'est évidemment pas du tout le cas
dans ce texte
vous allez me dire je suis un
développeur je suis l'aménageur et vous
attiré mon attention sur des
considérations sociales qui sont ici
hors sujet et vous savez bien que
développeur économique qui permettra
peut-être sans doute de créer de
nouveaux emplois et par voie de
conséquence à terme de réduire égalité
au quartier ne portera ses fruits qu'à
moyen terme et que les considérations
sociales notamment en termes de
tranquillité publique de qualité de vie
de qualité des services pèsent de tout
leur poids au mans pour les entreprises
de décider de leur lieu d'implantation
de plus il est indispensable de rappeler
que les aménagements que nous souhaitons
doivent se faire en tenant compte de la
préservation de l'environnement le
respect des espaces naturels et
agricoles doit être au coeur des débats
prenons l'exemple de londres dont on ne
peut que constater l'attractivité
économique la capitale britannique a
depuis longtemps déjà compris
l'importance d'allier confort de vie et
respect de l'environnement
ces nouveaux quartiers emporte la preuve
je pense par exemple au quartier de
bedzed achevée en 2002 qui est le plus
grand écho quartier du royaume uni qui
comprend des habitations des bureaux des
espaces delà des services tout cela à
quelques mythes en transport du centre
de londres
vous me direz qu'on pourrait mieux faire
encore pour ces concerts de la mixité
sociale au sein de ces quartiers j'en
conviens volontiers et je pense que nous
devons inventer une façon de faire ici
qui permettent de garder le meilleur de
l'expérience des quartiers
écologiquement un modèle comme ceux de
vauban à fribourg en breisgau ou de
bedzed à londres en garantissant la
mixité sociale et la diversité des
activités
j'ajoute que ce quartier a mis en place
un système de vente directe avec les
agriculteurs locaux et qu'il a veillé à
ne pas sacrifier les terres agricoles
qui demain seront précieuses y compris à
proximité immédiate de nos villes
tentant de transport réduits grâce à un
aménagement de zones de travail et
d'habitat se confondent maintiennent la
griffure local volonté de réduire notre
empreinte carbone
on est très loin avec votre projet de ce
modèle qui est le modèle pourtant porté
par le grenelle de l'environnement
dernier point il est indispensable que
des représentants élus des populations
des collectivités territoriales de
l'ensemble des institutions compétentes
et
légitime la région les départements les
communes les agglos le stif soient
consultés et associés au processus
décisionnel
la première richesse de la région c'est
sa population il est indispensable que
l'aménagement du territoire sont pensés
en fonction des besoins des attentes des
franciliens et pas plaquer sur la
réalité des territoires vécus
c'est ce que nous défendons travers cet
amendement que nous vous invitons à
soutenir
merci on enchaîne sur le 239 man abonnés
et en trois minutes honteux oui je serai
plus brèves monsieur le président
l'amendement 239,10 à mettre en
cohérence les objets réels du texte et
la définition de l'objet du projet de
loi de l'article 1
en modifiant les alinéas 1 et 2 du
premier article pour les mettre en
conformité avec le contenu véritable du
projet de loi présenté
nous sommes loin en dépit des
protestations de bonne volonté du
ministre d'un projet urbain social et
économique internationale
rien dans le texte ne pourra
malheureusement réduit les équilibres
sociaux territoriaux et fiscaux au
bénéfice de l'ensemble du territoire
national quant à la place réservée aux
collectivités territoriales aux citoyens
et les biens faible nous l'avons déjà
démontré j'espère d'ailleurs que nos
amendements présentés ultérieurement
allant dans le sens d'un processus
décisionnel plus participatif
recueilleront votre intérêt à l'est que
de ce projet de loi force est de
constater que la majeure partie du texte
se focalise sur un nouveau système de
transport le métro automatique dit grand
huit
soyons honnête donc avec nos concitoyens
le grand paris ne se fera pas au
bénéfice d'un cent du territoire
national la mise en place de ce métro
l'aménagement du plateau de saclay
n'auront aucune incidence le jugement
des franciliens sur la réduction de la
fracture territoriale ou le chômage
je vous propose donc de coller à la
réalité de ce projet douanes expliquant
doivent sur blanc que le projet de grand
paris se résume à la création d'un
réseau de transport qui allie des pôles
économiques et des aéroports merci chers
collègues amendement numéro 3 il est
présenté par madame d'humains
oui merci monsieur le président par cet
amendement
nous souhaitons mes collègues et moi
rappelé le poids de la zone centrale
c'est-à-dire paris et le coeur
d'agglomération dans le cadre du grand
paris est également faire en sorte que
son rôle déterminant le rôle déterminant
de paris soit clairement réaffirmé dans
les attendus du texte de loi
et je rappelle cet effet que sur 5 % du
territoire francilien sur ce territoire
parisien plus de 50% de la population et
70% des emplois de la région sont
concentrées également 90 % des
déplacements sont concentrés sur ce
territoire de paris et coeur
d'agglomération
merci chers collègues
l'amendement 106e rectifier il est
présenté par monsieur dominati merci
monsieur le président pas cet amendement
je souhaite que le gouvernement donne
une réponse à une question qui a été
posée à plusieurs reprises
c'est à savoir la gouvernance le
périmètre et le budget alloué à au
projet considéré est l'ambition qui est
la nôtre il est paradoxal de considérer
que ces critères sont essentielles dans
une france contemporaine et que le
gouvernement s'est engagé avec
résolution dans une réforme sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui est la
réforme territoriale que pour ma part
j'ai soutenu avec un certain nombre de
mes collègues
avec cette ambition et on nous dit que
pour l'île de france on a une ambition
encore plus forte et on est à la traîne
alors pendant combien de temps
allons-nous être à la traîne
j'ai évoqué hier la réussite des
transports régionaux dans toutes les
régions sauf dans celles où l'état veut
garder la prédominance je voudrais
savoir si pour la région ile de france
il est prévu quelque chose dans ce
calendrier puisque c'est la différence
et la distinction qu'il y aura entre une
loi à projets politiques et une loi de
nature technique
c'est le but de cet amendement
merci chers collègues amendement 246 il
est présenté par madame voynet 242
garderie suédois 242
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez expliqué hier et le
rapporteur l'avait confirmé et à centrer
passionné que les contrats de
développement territorial n'avait pas
pour objet de vider de leur sens et de
leurs moyens financiers les contrats de
projet élaboré conjointement par l'état
et la région
je profite d'ailleurs ce sera peut-être
une petite incidente pour dire que là où
certains ont dénoncé du saupoudrage en
contenu des contrats de projet il faut
pointer le fait que l'état met tout son
poids pour obtenir que des éléments qui
n'étaient pas prioritaires pour la
région et dont le financement lui
incombaient et à lui seul soit inscrite
au contrat de projet bénéficie du
soutien financier de la région et
éventuellement d'autres collectivités
c'est le cas évidemment dans la plupart
des régions pour les tgv c'est le cas
dans la nôtre pour la vie étudiante par
exemple pour d'autres politiques
essentielles à d'autres pays que la
région finance donc sans se faire prier
parce qu'elles sont essentielles et donc
vous nous expliquer que ce contrat
développement territorial ne concurrence
pas la région mais qui seront néanmoins
mis en oeuvre conjointement par l'état
et les communes sans la région elle même
je souhaite par cet amendement vous
prendre au mot en réécrivant dans un
sens peut-être plus conforme à l usage
français le l'aligner en question mais
je pense qu'il est quand même absolument
indispensable de faire en sorte que
l'objectif de construction de 70000
logements en ile de france chaque année
soit conforme au schéma directeur de la
région
les franciliens considère la politique
du logement comme une priorité absolue
ils ont redit par la présente campagne
pour les élections régionales leurs
attentes leurs inquiétudes
je crois qu'il est important de ne pas
laisser planer l'idée que l'état
pourrait décider seuls des implantations
de logements et que c'est bien sûr la
base du travail élaboré en commun par
les acteurs locaux dans le cadre du
sdrif que nous pourrons nous appuyer
je vous propose par ailleurs d'ajouter
une garantie de construction logements
sociaux en 2009 28 % des candidats à un
logement social ont rempli une demande
en ile de france la région est en flux
tendu évidemment matière de logement
nous proposons donc de préciser que les
contrats développement territorial
devront prévoir la production d'au moins
30 % de logements sociaux sur chaque
territoire concerné merci chers
collègues
l'amendement de rectifier il est
présenté par madame dumas alors cet
amendement est relatif à la croissance
économique de l'île de france et nous
souhaitons intégrer dans l'article
premier du texte de loi un objectif de
croissance moyenne qui serait comparable
à celui observé dans les grandes
capitales européennes
merci amendement 240 peut capter il est
présenté par madame voynet 244
et si monsieur le président je suis
prise en flagrant délit grave deux
bavardages avec brick nous nous
rappelions quelques hauts faits du passé
notre rapporteur concernant
effectivement des contrats passés entre
l'état et la région à propos de réseau
de transport public
mais je ne doute pas que nicole bricq le
rappellera le moment venu concernant
l'amendement 244 plusieurs architectes
consultés dans le cadre du projet de
grand paris ont rappelé l'importance du
maillage du réseau de transports en ile
de france
en effet pour développer un système
efficace il est important de privilégier
les correspondances entre les différents
moyens de transport pour faciliter la
vie des franciliens rentre plus
accessible des zones aujourd'hui engorgé
comme le quartier de la défense on ne
s'intéresse pas uniquement au logement
en est parfaitement capable
effectivement de prendre en compte aussi
les difficultés de desserts que certains
quartiers à la vitalité économique
reconnu le maillage et transport serait
le meilleur moyen d'améliorer la
mobilité franciliennes comme la firme en
2007 réseau ferré de france
cela permettrait des déplacements plus
rapides puis simple de banlieue à
banlieue être à moins chargée en zone
dense une diminution de la congestion et
la pollution routière en banlieue
adaptons notre réseau de transport
développons un schéma en toile
d'araignée dans toute la région et non
seulement vers les zones de fort
développement économique
le projet de grand huit favorise les
déplacements travail de travail quelques
pour cent à peine du talent des
déplacements il pourrait favoriser
davantage les déplacements des habitants
de l'ouest parisien
mais resterait jacques mahias à
démontrer effroyablement inégalitaire
pour ce concert des habitants de l'est
parisien
pour cette raison nous vous proposons
par cet amendement de réaffirmer
l'importance de l'articulation entre les
transports existants les transports à
venir pour réduire les déséquilibres
territoriaux
cela bien sûr dans le cadre du respect
du travail réalisé dans cette région par
le schéma directeur de la région ile de
france
merci chers collègues amendement 303 il
est présenté par monsieur v oui merci
monsieur le président chers collègues
sur ministre dans le projet grand paris
bien entendu l'essentiel des actions qui
sont prévues concernent la région
francilienne
mais lorsqu'il a été annoncé le projet
grand paris
il y a aussi et c'était clairement
manifestée par le président de la
république la volonté d'ouvrir paris et
la région parisienne sur le grand large
et pour cela non seulement de faire en
sorte que les grands ports de l'axé
seine paris bien entendu mais rouen le
havre notamment puissent se développer
et pour se développer il faut qu'il y
ait des moyens de transport et donc il
est prévu une ligne grande vitesse qui
concerne monsieur le président tant la
basse-normandie que la haute-normandie
et je sais monsieur le président que
vous y est attaché comme mes collègues
par patrice gélard et catherine morin
desailly est donc quelque part si l'on
veut que ça fonctionne tout à la fois
pour les voyageurs et pour le fret
eh bien il faut qu'il y ait une bonne
coordination et que les trains puissent
aller le plus vite possible sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
bien sûr à paris sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et même au delà
à l'échelon de l'europe et donc j'avais
déposé un premier amendement qui avait
été adopté par la commission monsieur le
rapporteur je remercie mais madame
voynet a déposé un amendement qui a
donné une nouvelle version de celle de
ses paragraphes 5
alors moi bien entendu je n'ai rien
contre les dispositions de l'amendement
que vient de présenter madame voynet
mais ceci étant si ça met bien en
évidence la coordination des moyens de
transport dans la région parisienne
salle mais un peu moins pour les
interconnexions et temps routière fait
le fluvial que ferroviaire avec les
ensembles d autres régions
et c'est dans ce sens que j'ai déposé
cet amendement monsieur le président qui
propose d'ajouter fluvial à ferroviaire
et routier et qui eux à travers ces
interconnexions
permet de donner des raisons plus rapide
avec les autres régions pour éviter en
fait d'entrer dans paris comme nous le
faisons tout de suite de changer de gare
à gare pour dès lors qu'on veut aller
très souvent dans une autre région ou de
venir encombrer la région parisienne
paris ou le périphérique voilà le sens
de l'amendement monsieur le président
qui est j'ai déposé merci chers
collègues
alors monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis de la commission sur ces neuf
amendements et sous amendement merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
passer en revue les amendements sur
l'amendement numéro 10 de monsieur verra
il récrit de manière différente
l'article 1er il parle du
conditionnement de l'aide publique aux
entreprises la réalisation d'objectifs
d'amélioration qualitative de l'offre
d'emploi de l'offre de formation qui
sont des sujets tout à fait extérieur au
texte dont nous discutons et par
conséquent la commission a émis un avis
défavorable
il allait même pour l'amendement numéro
2 138 qui d'ailleurs prévoit les mêmes
choses et qui ne correspond pas aux
textes qui est sorti de la commission
dont avis défavorable sur l'amendement
numéro 2 139 de madame voynet avis
également défavorable part que cet
amendement réduit le grand paris un
simple projet de transports alors que
nous avons vu qu'il dépassait largement
cet objectif et donc avis défavorable
sur l'amendement numéro 3 de madame
dumas de monsieur dominati et pozzo di
borgo
la commission a donné un avis favorable
de manière à remettre au premier rang
paris est le coeur de l'agglomération
parisienne sur l'amendement de monsieur
dominati numéro 106 rectifier j'ai
compris que c'était un amendement
d'appel au gouvernement la commission a
observé qu'il s'agissait d'un amendement
injonctif à l'égard du gouvernement qui
est donc tout à fait comment dirais-je
pas conformes aux textes
constitutionnels
et par conséquent je suis partisan que
monsieur dominati une fois qu'il aura
reçu les explications du ministre puisse
leur tirait sur l'amendement numéro 2
142 madame voynet avis défavorable
puisque il conditionne dans la création
logements aux objectifs du strip de 1994
qui commence à devenir un peu obsolète
sur l'amendement numéro 2 rectifiez de
madame dumas de monsieur dominati et
pozzo di borgo
la commission a émis un avis favorable
sur l'amendement numéro 2 144 de madame
voynet et ses collègues
la commission a émis un avis favorable
parce qu'ils montrent bien
l'articulation avec le réseau
préexistant et sur le sous-amendement
numéro 303 du président sur le
sous-amendement de monsieur revel qui
complètent l'amendement de madame voynet
en introduisant le mot fluvial et
routier terrestres et fluviales et qui
reprend la fin du texte que la
commission avait adoptée gb également un
avis favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre quel est l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le président concernant
l'amendement numéro 10 même avis que
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
concernant le 238 avis également
défavorable concernant l'amendement
numéro 2 139 avis défavorable puisque
c'est un amendement qui réduire l
ambition du projet à la réalisation d'un
métro amendement numéro 3
je suis plutôt favorable à cet
amendement
la préoccupation exprimée par madame
dumas et le gouvernement l'a intégré dès
le départ c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
la la double boucle n'est pas simplement
une simple boucle car il nous est apparu
indispensable dès le début de nos
réflexions de penser un réseau non pas
qu'ils évitent la ville de paris mais
qui crée autour d'elle non pas un
nouveau périphérique mais un réseau qui
permet de communiquer entre le coeur de
paris avec les autres territoires
stratégiques de la région et entre les
territoires stratégiques entre eux donc
je rejoins la position du rapporteur
favorable concernant l'amendement de
monsieur dominati numéro 106 j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous dire hier monsieur
dominati que la question de la
gouvernance que vous soulevez au travers
de
cet amendement est de façon évidente une
autre question essentielle l'horizon de
temps que vous évoquez 2014 paraît
raisonnable ce qui donne le temps pour
que sur tous les territoires de la
région capitale émergent des projets
concrets et que les questions de la
gouvernance puisse se poser sur des
bases sûres et collectivement accepté
par tous mais je me pu être favorable à
ce stade à ce que l'on inscrive dans la
loi une telle disposition et c'est
pourquoi si l'on est d'accord je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez retirer
votre amendement concernant l'amendement
numéro 2 140 2 je rejoins le rapporteur
défavorable concernant l'amendement
numéro deux avis favorable concernant
l'amendement numéro 2 144
je voudrais dire ma voix n'est que je
n'ai pas réellement d'avis sur la
meilleure écriture de ce 5ème alinéa
mais au delà des questions
rédactionnelles le texte de votre
commission spéciale et votre amendement
on met en avant une question essentielle
le réseau du grand paris dont nous
discuterons plus avant l'article 2
dépasse en effet de très loin en terme
dans le jeu la question des transports
régionaux
je le rappelle une des ambitions du
réseau du grand paris est en effet de
relier entre elles les grandes gares
ferroviaires pour faciliter les liaisons
région-capitale province ou province
province
n'oublions pas que
le nombre d'habitants de la région
capitale qui conserve des liens forts
familiaux affectifs ou encore
professionnels avec les autres régions
françaises est très présent au delà même
de ses liens il s'agit de promouvoir et
c'est au plan économique très important
il s'agit de promouvoir les synergies
entre les grandes régions françaises
cet alinéa à 5 met également en avant le
nécessaire maillage avec le réseau
routier
je ne peux que me réjouir à l'envoi
n'est qu'un tel amendement soit porté
par vous je suis même convaincu qu'un
tel maillage avec le réseau routier peut
permettre tout à la fois de favoriser
l'intermodalité et de contribuer au
décongestionnement des grands axes
routiers et sur ce point nous avons
lancé des études pour vérifier la
faisabilité de placer tel ou tel gars
sur les grands axes autoroutiers et d'y
adjoindre d'importants parkings relais
dimensionné et adéquat pour enfin toutes
ces raisons montre que si c'est l'état
qui porte un tel projet
ce n'est pas parce que la région on
n'est pas capable c'est uniquement parce
que cela va très au delà de ses
compétences pour un projet dont
l'intérêt est véritablement nationale
concernant l'amendement numéro 303
favorable concernant et c'est tout
et c'est tout merci merci et il est très
bien alors sur l'amendement numéro 10 il
y at-il de demandes d'explications de
vote s'il n'y en a pas que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veut bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main l'amendement
n'est pas adoptée sur le 238 même vote
même vote sur les 239 même vote même
vote un moment numéro 3 toujours pas de
demandes d'explications de vote si
monsieur veiller sur président monsieur
le ministre je vais bien évidemment voté
pour cet amendement puisque notre
collègue élu de paris désigne sous le
nom de coeur de l'agglomération le 75 92
le 93 et le 94
il se trouve que par un heureux hasard
cela correspond exactement aux
périmètres que j'avais retenu dans mon
rapport sur un projet de gouvernance
pour le grand paris cela démontre long
qu'une chose que l'on soit élu de paris
élue de la proche banlieue ou de la
grande banlieue tout le monde sent bien
qu'il y à une zone dense alors appelons
la comme nous voulons avec ses
spécificités et que cette zone dense il
faut bien la prendre en considération
parce qu'elle ne peut pas être traité
parce qu'elle n'a pas les mêmes
problèmes comme le reste du territoire
de la région ile-de-france alors j'y
reviendrai dans ce débat mais je voulais
saisir l'occasion pour le rappeler et
soutenir peut-être avant que notre
collègue le retire l'amendement suivant
qui effectivement fixer une date pour
une véritable proposition de réforme de
la gouvernance
alors je crains effectivement qui ne le
retire monsieur le ministre ce qui me
désole c'est que on en parle on en parle
on en parle de la réforme de la
gouvernance et on me répondent toujours
baissés pour bientôt alors bien peu
l'impression quand même que c'est comme
l'horizon plus on avance plus ça
s'éloigne et je ne vois pas venir le
moment où effectivement une véritable
proposition sera formulée alors je
comprends que vous ne répondiez encore
que vous préférez voir les projets
émerger
avant qu'un projet de réforme de la
gouvernance ne soit mis sur la table
mais ça me perturbe malgré tout parce
que on va le voir au travers de la suite
de la discussion
votre projet va s'articuler autour des
fameux contrats de développement
territorial on va y revenir
ces contrats de développement 40 gares
40 contrats ils vont donc j'ai
effectivement modeler ce territoire avec
des objectifs qui leur seront propres en
termes de logement en termes de
transport mais au bout du compte est ce
qu'on aura bien un projet métropolitain
et est ce que l'on pourra plaqué sur ses
projets de développement de ces 40
territoire identifié un projet de
gouvernance de la métropole
moi j'en doute encore aujourd'hui et
voilà pourquoi j'aurais aimé que nous
fixions cette date
et qu'enfin nous nous mettions les uns
et les autres autour de la table pour à
échéance 12 ou 24 mois et bien
effectivement formulé une proposition je
regrette peut-être un peu par avance
mais que ça ne soit pas une nouvelle
fois le cas merci chers collègues et
monsieur pozzo di borgo pour explication
de vote
mon explication de vote a touché cet
amendement et puis le suivant qui je
pense va être retirée je veux jouer et
redire ce que j'ai déjà dit en séance
mais je crois que c'est quand même un
des point fondamental et le mr l'a dit
l'île de france souffre d'un empilage
des structures la musique la
multiplicité des acteurs l'état la
région département communes et
intercommunalités au monde des charges
publiques nuit à la cohérence et à
l'efficace y est l'addition public en
particulier en matière de transports et
déplacements
on a bien vu si le grand paris et fait
partie des tasses et qui à personne que
cette vision générale mais aussi en
matière de logement de man is
développement économique et
d'équipements structurants le coeur de
l'agglomération janvier instamment pâti
de l'absence de politique commune
alors j'ai déjà fait la remarque
fait malgré un pelage des structures
dans l'île de france
vous savez qu'en france le taux de
couverture intercommunale et 2 89 90 %
bâtiment alors que dans l'île de france
quand on navigue 1% ce chiffre d g l
alors que pour l'île de france
il est simplement de 56% il n'y a pas de
vision collective pour affronter la
concurrence mondiale avec une masse
critique suffisante
la plupart des grandes villes
européennes l'ont dans 97 ont regroupé
ces collectivités locales comprises dans
leur aire urbaine pour organiser
développement et leur aménagement
je prendrai l'exemple de lyon
l'agglomération lyonnaise par un texte
de loi de 1966 a pu a pu créer une
communauté urbaine et bénéficie d'une
gestion humaine passé suggère une
autorité administrative unique depuis 40
ans et depuis 20 ans je le rappelle lyon
figure parmi les vingt villes
européennes et qui progressent toutes
catégories confondues jugées les plus
attractives
depuis 40 ans paris et lyon ont ainsi
connu une évolution administrative
exactement inverse alors que la loi de
66 a permis à l'agglomération lyonnaise
de regrouper ses forces et de
rationaliser la sous utilisation de ses
moyens administratifs techniques et
financiers la disparition du département
de la seine en 1964 a signifié pour le
coeur l'agglomération parisienne
l'éparpillement et la dilution que nous
continuons à payer cette absence de
structures de gouvernance et spitz les
chiffres la moindre croissance de l'île
de france
malgré sa puissance économique alors on
aurait pu très bien faire un amendement
sur la loi de 66 et rajouter parce qu'à
l'époque soit six cadres à créer des
communautés urbaines paris n'était pas
une commune donc on aurait pu très bien
faire sous le texte des collectivités
territoriales ce texte à un amendement
dans lequel on crée une communauté
urbaine à paris on aurait pu très bien
aussi derrière le texte de loi sera
votée récupérer le gros sel de
métropoles en seulement moi je m'adresse
à mes collègues de la gauche
comment prendre en soixante ans que
lorsqu'on a fait le département de la
seine la vision politique à la
l' époque affecté le département de la
seine si le mes problèmes connaît
actuellement il ya quinze ans c'est vrai
que c'était la droite et le centre qui
dirige l ile-de-france a lavé par ilham
ile-de-france à 8 déprécie département
sur e sur 8 celle inverse maintenant la
gauche à la région
la gauche à paris la gauche à six
départements sur huit
alors moi je me mets à la place de ces
cafés puisqu'une somme en sambo gausser
de paris quand monsieur delanoë
typiquement créé le paris métropole
mais on voit très bien qui est très gêné
par la présence du président de la
région à côté donc il fait petit à petit
dix ans pour faire un paris métropole
qui déstructure d'études on lui parle de
communauté urbaine a surtout pas ça fera
un problème au sein du parti socialiste
mes coups étaient frappés qu'on le
pousse ce problème un jour ou l'autre
mais il faudrait bien quand le pot se
prennent au jeu ou l'autre il faudra
qu'on ait le courage
il faudra qu'on ait le courage si vous
voulez d'aborder ce problème de
gouvernance c'est nécessaire pour
l'évolution de l'île de france c'est
nécessaire pour cette île de france soit
en fait une région qu'ils puissent
adapter à ces loppement économie alors
j'ai un peu politisés des choses soit
peut être aussi chez nous aussi il ya
aussi des raisons qui font qu'on n'ose
pas aborder ce problème là je le dis je
dis parce qu il nécessaire il est
nécessaire il est nécessaire que la
collective et que là le sénat sont au
courant des choses voilà le ton je vous
remercie monsieur masson pour
explication de vote
oui monsieur le président bon je ne suis
pas contrariant donc je voterai cet
amendement mais je me pose quand même
une question sur l'intérêt de nos débats
parce que quand on voit le texte de
l'amendement et tout le monde se plaint
de ce que le parlement fasse des tests
qui n'ont aucune d'applications aucun
effet concret on se demande quel est
l'impact de cet amendement de l'ancienne
et as de la version s'il propose de
modifier par rapport à la nouvelle
version
moi je ne comprends pas très bien enfin
je suis un humble provincial et je me
demande très honnêtement s'il est
pertinent de faire un article 1er
particulièrement longs ont fait de
considérations générales etc qui n'ont
strictement aucun impact en droit
positif et cet amendement ne change
strictement rien alors je le voterai pas
ce que je lis bien je ne suis pas
contrariant mais je me demande s'il est
pertinent que l'ensemble de nos débats
s'articule sur des choses qui ont un
intérêt quand même relativement limité
compte tenu des grands problèmes qui se
posent à la nation actuellement ceci
étant si quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ce
que cet amendement change e
concrètement dans la vie de l'île de
france ça m'aiderait beaucoup et ça
m'encourage là encore plus a voté pour
mais moi je n'ai pas compris je suis un
humble petit sénateurs provincial je le
répète mais j'ai pas compris l'intérêt
du site de cet amendement merci cher
collègue monsieur café pour explication
de vote
merci monsieur le président vous
comprendrez bien que il ne s'agit pas à
proprement parler une explication de
vote sur un amendement déposé par des
collègues de la majorité sur laquelle je
n'est pas je n'avais pas l'intention à
priori d'intervenir mais puisque
monsieur monsieur pozzo di borgo m'a
interpellé nommément et directement
je vois difficilement comment je ne
pourrais pas répondre
alors je voudrais faire remarquer à
monsieur pozzo di borgo que
contrairement à vous monsieur d'allier a
eu l'élégance de poser un problème celui
de la gouvernance de l'ile-de-france que
d'un problème récurrent depuis déjà des
années qui risquent de l'être monsieur
pozzo di borgo pendant encore des années
et que monsieur d'allier a eu l'élégance
de pointer ce problème qu'il connaît
mieux que d'autres sans doute monsieur
pozzo di borgo puisque il est l'auteur
d'un rapport mais enfin vous vous avez
voulu me mettre en cause est bien
évidemment à travers moi le maire de
paris alors monsieur pozzo di borgo je
voudrais vous dire plusieurs choses la
première c'est que vous avez un
vocabulaire particulier quand vous dites
que avancer la droite qui avait les
départements et que maintenant c'est la
gauche qui à paris et qui a des
départements je vous dis que c'est un
langage qui m'est étranger car nous
n'avons pas une propriété patrimoniale
des mandats dont nous disposons première
chose
non monsieur pozzo di borgo
nous ne sommes pas propriétaires de
paris nous ne sommes pas propriétaires
des départements nous ne sommes pas
propriétaires des deux de la région
nous sommes simplement les mandataires
des lecteurs qui nous ont fait confiance
et ils nous l'ont fait encore il ya
quelques semaines
première chose deuxième chose je
voudrais vous faire remarquer monsieur
pozzo di borgo que vous ne manquez pas
de toupet car c'est depuis 2001 que la
ville de paris est sorti de son
splendide isolement
alors qu'avant pendant des décennies est
d'exporter toutes ces nuisances en
banlieue et un certain nombre de maires
de banlieues de la majorité pourraient
largement en témoigner car eux on
exportait pas simplement les ordures en
exportait a en même temps les cimetières
tu es bien d'autres choses et donc c'est
vrai qu'il vient une rupture en 2001 et
d'ailleurs vous êtes le premier à
reconnaître parfois au conseil de paris
monsieur pozzo di borgo
cette rupture en 2001 et la main tendue
de paris bat sous des formes
particulières évidemment mais avec des
contrats qui ont été signés
la main tendue de paris un certain
nombre de communes de banlieue et de
départements de banlieue
troisièmement monsieur pozzo di borgo
cette question est une question qui est
essentielle mais dont vous savez
pertinemment qu'elle ne résoudra pas
qu'elle ne se résoudra pas d'un coup de
baguette magique et excusez moi de vous
dire
peut-être avons-nous des débats entre la
ville de paris et la région
peut-être avons-nous un certain nombre
de nuances je parle de nuances dans
l'appréciation de la structure
institutionnelle qui devrait venir s'il
en a une qui vient mais je n'ai pas eu
le sentiment jusqu'à présent que dans la
majorité il y ait véritablement un point
de vue qui soit absolument convergent et
y fasse l'unanimité chez vous j'en veux
d'ailleurs pourquoi monsieur pozzo di
borgo et j'en termine